alright time for some rapid chess it's a
monthly let rapid arena and I'm playing
ego strizheus I'll just play probably a
handful of games
try and get some instructive playing
playing against a London let's play d5
I'll play what I normally play against a
London
usually involving c5 knight c6 and Queen
b6 and I'll try and make this
instructive hopefully play decently more
instructive than yesterday at least just
a mess of like rapid chess or bullet
chess in chess960 so he's playing Bishop
d3 usually people start with Knight f3
after which I would play Queen b6 I
think I can still play Queen b6 and this
is a one kind of target in the London
especially when this Bishop develops
early is a b2 pawn is not defended and I
move like Queen c2 sometimes runs into
c5 or c4 and then Bishop e2 and then I
have Bishop f5 and if I place Queen b3 I
probably still play c4 so White has some
decision to make how to defend the pawn
maybe let me take the pawn we'll see
hello to people in the chats thermos
lolly it's queer couple haywire habit ly
tvy Dreamfall
thanks guys for watching joining early
Queen c2 ok so this will be a nice line
c4 the bishop has to retreat and then I
get to play Bishop a5 this is a very
typical idea
now there's funny situations if I didn't
develop my Knights I was still on b8
then
I could take on a five and if I take on
b2 then Queen c8 would be mates and
there's situations where this has
happened before
but okay in this position the bishop
can't be taken a queen has to stay
guarding the pawn now e6 is the most
natural move here
I'll probably just play it there's cases
where like if the bishop were running on
e 2 I would like to play Knight h5 get
the bishop pair but I'm happy life is
good
I'll probably throw in h6 just making
sure that if Knight each four I have
have a way to maintain the bishop and so
I'm a very nice diagonal and this is a
sort of structure where like both
bishops are happy this Bishop is outside
the pawn chain this Bishop just controls
the dark squares now there's not really
too many squares this bishop can develop
to only square is really e7 and then I
can castle and then usually the middle
game plan okay we'll get to the middle
game eventually after castling is
usually to move the Queen either back to
d8 sometimes to a6 and play B 5 B 4 hey
there's more people in the chat look
away for a moment notification squad
Vargas Parham are something Bo 92 92
lets castle
to be a little bit careful for d7 things
but okay my knights controlling d7 I'll
probably take with the pawn could take
with the Queen mmm some interesting
decision if I take with pawn I would
really want to play rook b8 this bishops
annoying take with Queen the plan is
more straightforward it could walk into
some Knight move then I moved back to b6
let's stick with Queen just simple plan
now B 5 B 4 I just want to create
weaknesses and if the B file opens
neither of us have access to to the like
the square for the rook so I might have
some idea of playing Bishop d6 like long
term plan is to open the B file trade
off bishops and then dominate the B file
ok let's play b5 this is kind of what I
was expecting maybe Queen b7 just making
sure that I'm not getting attacked on d7
like ever g4 is a little bit surprising
but I think I'm okay like white is
clearly going for an attack just not
stopping g5 okay so I probably have to
take probably takes and then like 94 the
G file is open but White's King no
longer has like a great home it's
probably just gonna stay in the center
and then I mean the Queen can't really
come in to help the attack
I still have ideas of this feeling good
Bishop's got traded take on you seven of
the Queen looming ideas of f6 to chasten
either way there's more people I would
say hi to everyone
but it's difficult and it's bits I'll
say hi to Rob Oh Rob of thanks for the
hundred bits I'm in some money you have
school it is a weekday I guess but
what's more educational school or
watching me probably school but what's
more fun more importantly Bishop f4 so
that's probably the best move keeping
Bishop's on the board now I could
consider g5f six these are some forcing
options I think I'll play b4 first
because there's actually some tactical
idea I'm threatening to take twice on c3
because Queen takes c3 and the end is
met with Bishop to b4 and we're already
seeing the king being a little bit
problematic for whites Ani one
your internet is bad I'm sorry about
that
my Internet's actually the house I'm
staying at the internet went down so I'm
on the neighbor's Wi-Fi which is
actually pretty fast as far as I can
tell
hopefully it memory remains that way I'm
in some money with a thousand bits what
does that say I would enlarge it best
soul on twitch well thank you there's a
saying who said it I think Philidor said
its pawns are the soul of chess now I'm
sitting or now I'm in Samadhi saying
that I'm the soul on twitch not sure if
the two are related
can I just take on c3 twice do I have to
worry about this move I should age six
it's confusing and takes Bishop h6 and I
take again as rook takes I just move
over it's probably working let's take at
least once
I'm trying to calculate this line like
take sticks Bishop h6 take on e - I
should probably take some precautions
like the positions really nice I should
probably just throw in King h8 be safe
sometimes you have to stop the pawns
threats before carrying through with
your own threats like now King h8 no
White has rook be one at six is also in
the buff wait a minute I have Bishop f6
but if I play Bishop f6 sudden there's
no more like there should be five ideas
I want to do something fun but also be
controlled
I take c3 Bishop there especially six
takes takes f6 right away so f6 Bishop
h6 I take it's kind of messy I'm just
gonna be safe go with the idea I
mentioned earlier this does allow rook
b1 then I'll probably move the Queen
over and then maybe I have tactics and
I'll try and fight for the B file Joe
Bruni and the chats shout out to Joe
Brune been watching some of your streams
at least trying to
Yury subbed about 10 minutes before you
started ah as a notification there
Tomko maybe it didn't pop up maybe it
doesn't pop up if I'm not streaming well
thanks for the resub top go white noise
is making me hungry the steak emotes and
cold player with a sub thanks cold
player eight-months
what do I think of Rasheed how do I say
this name Neji Medina you should ask a
good mater I think he has pretty strong
opinions okay Bishop f3 so now I'm very
tempted I mean this is just simple
tactics takes I even know what to
calculate like I'm just winning upon and
this is just uh a poisonous Knights now
there's no more rook b1 I'm controlling
v1 with three pieces and now I have
ideas of like Bishop before you know I
could try and run away so it'll still
take some work to win this but I'm
willing to put in the work
at some point I probably want to play f6
don't really want to allow this though
she have a funny idea to play G v g5
Bishop takes g5 and then s6 with a fork
but I don't know if I should leave my
nights hanging because now white is
actually threatening to take the nights
so let's just move back and be happy
this is reasonable and now Africa p1 I
have tactics please play rook e1 you
know you want to open file attack the
Queen just do it oh he did it
I wasn't even using reverse psychology
I'm pretty sure I can just take this and
I'm winning like a full rook this bishop
this bishop is a sniper who said the
bishop was a sniper someone did whoever
said it you're right am i meeting
I'm almost mating Bishop d3 don't have
my queen but I have minor pieces King G
1 is coming Knight see okay II won so
where's a mating net ah this looks so
much fun
so Bishop before he has to play this and
then I just pushed the C pawn so there's
some line like c3 Knight takes off 8c to
king c1 Bishop here King B 2 or B 1 King
a 1 and then Bishop c3 is mate just take
the rook oh wait a minute c2 King c1
Bishop e3 is a quicker mate more
efficient because the knight on b1
controls
d2 okay that was nice that's a nice kind
of London takedown I'll probably put
that on YouTube
do I have to do any analysis for YouTube
make all the analysis was kind of
mentioned during the game one
recommendation for the London players
out there if you run into this line and
you play this move order moves like
Bishop d3 or Knight f3 I don't think I
recommended because of Queen b6 so as
far as I know the best move for white in
this position is Knight d2 with the idea
that after Queen b6 white can play Queen
to b3 and then if black goes for
basically the same idea which I played
in the game
c4 Queen c2 I don't have Bishop f5
because the rook is not getting trapped
and this is actually a good line for
whites because e4 will come next so just
run one recommendation if my opponent
played in 92 I probably would have
decided between east 6 or Bishop f5 and
then it's playable for both sides so
yeah YouTube people watching in the
future thanks for watching you can smash
the subscribe button on YouTube and also
preferably twitch and I'll see you in
the next video